we are learning more and more details
about the effort to find and rescue ron
and beverly barker they were the couple
that recently got lost during a road
trip up in northern nevada so only
beverly was found alive search crews say
both vehicles they were traveling with
were actually stuck off the main road
and they were in a very difficult spot
to even locate christian gossip is
joining us now live in studio with
really the heartbreaking images that
have just come into the newsroom that's
right guys well today we spoke to one of
the members from that search and rescue
team and they tell us that it was
obvious how this couple did their best
to survive
a challenging mission for dave sparks
and his search and rescue team both of
these vehicles pulled out within minutes
after being stuck in a rural nevada
mountain for days it was awful to see
because you could feel
their stress in in coming across the
mess you could see their
distressed items the water bottles the
masks that she was using to try to
collect water ron and beverly barker
were on a recent road trip traveling
inside the rv and pulling their kia soul
when they became lost in esmeralda
county near silver peak they leave the
scene of the rv to go try to find help
they're going down these terrible roads
in this kia soul and what it boiled down
to was
they took one wrong turn off of the main
trail is what ended up putting them down
in a ravine spark says the series of
mistakes were very clear but
heartbreaking as the elderly couple did
what they could to survive i got real
choked up when i saw her walker just
sitting there
you know by the door of her car and
she'd been trying to climb up and down
that mountain after seven days the
couple was found but ron did not survive
beverly recovering at a reno hospital
according to family and in good spirits
search crews returning the rv to the
family and sending this message to
everyone hitting the roads even driving
around in your regular everyday car you
should buy one of those little medical
you know care kits just
you can never be over prepared
well sparks also telling us that the rv
and the kia were found just a short
distance from each other and really
hidden from the public eye a devastating
situation he says but a miracle beverly
survived christian castle is live local
now